have you any idea what time it is it's too late
for a doctor's wife to be up aren't you coming
to bed soon yes just as soon as I finish
planning my talk for the high school I'm
to speak to them Wednesday you know young people
again you have operations tomorrow and patients
to care for you need rest George they're giving
too much of your time to be young please Emily
if I can help just one young girl a boy to get
a better start in life if I can steer them away
from some of the dangers that it took me years
to learn about I'll be glad I gave this time
yes dear I know but do try to do anything now
you run along I'll be through in a few minutes
yes don't you dr. Elliot
young Harry party he's still unconscious
I'll be right over yes
what happened to Harry Barton they don't seem
to know head injury of some kind where are they
City Hospital George we can't operate with
his Beach oh thanks dear I'll be back soon
hey wake up [ __ ] you'll be late for school
I'll be down right away Jack what time is it
it's Saturday goofy don't you remember the
party last night why do girls have to have
brothers to wake up sisters how do you feel
terrible you were looking wonder how Harry
feels this morning why are you sure was a clown
last night he'll be bouncing around right after
breakfast yeah Jane look here Harry Barton
seriously injured found unconscious in the
street Jack what happened to him but they
don't know listen early this morning Harry
pardons son of a prominent local family was
found unconscious at 14th and Avenue age he
was immediately rushed to the hospital with dr.
Elliot gave emergency treatment his condition
is reported critical place unable to find any
witnesses because of the injury is unknown gene
where did we leave Harry last night what
teeth and have a new way jack I'm scared I
take it easy I'm going to call the hospital
wait they will you tell you anything let's
go ask dr. Elliot he's just down the block away
spike we can talk to him I'll get dressed right
away no listen don't say a word about our
being with Harry I'll meet you downstairs
doctor we simply must find out something
about Harry how is he done we figured
you tell us about him knowing what
good friends I wish I could take is
it serious how serious we can tell Harry
has a skull fracture there may be a brain
we can only wait and watch develops we
have an operation we may have to operate
well may we go see oh we can't see anyone no dr.
Elliott haven't they any idea what happened to
me no they haven't could he have been hit by
an automobile perhaps c-could this kind of an
injury of come from stumbling falling very
easily his hand apparently struck the curb
dr. Elliott can you tell about what time this
accident happened somewhere around midnight we
will with Harry last night - about this night
the three of us went to a movie first then we
dropped in at the blue moon yeah well you know
how it is acting over you he'd get kinda thirsty
so we had some drinks but just a couple of
beers Oh beer but there isn't anything in
beer to make anyone drunk the person who is
drunk about the picture it's a person will
get printed like this trouble well what do you
mean we're the few beers we had couldn't have
had anything to do with Harry's accident well
played we can't dismiss beer that easily jack
here let me show you something here are some
things I got together to use in my
talk to the high school tomorrow
there is alcohol in beer the alcohol has a way of
doing things up here that few people
understand here take a look at this
this is the amount of alcohol in the
bottle of ordinary beer half an ounce
now this whiskey glass holds a shot an ounce
of whiskey which is half alcohol now what
more hits just the same amount this just as much
alcohol and a bottle of beers there isn't a shot
of whiskey that's right that's just what I
wanted you to see I never realized there's
that much alcohol a bottle of beer doctor what did
you mean when you said alcohol does funny things
up here well we all know that certain things
happen to a person when he drinks I'm going to
show you a little about what makes him different
to me let you see for yourself what's one of the
first changes you notice when a person has a
few drinks they begin to talk about so that's
you Jane no that's not Jane that's anybody why do
they talk about because their sense of hearing is
dull they can't hear their own voices in ordinary
tone they talk loudly for their own benefit not
yours why is that well alcohol is a nut coffee
it numbs a nerve centers by which we hear and
see smell and taste think and move it slows our
activity that's why the drinker can't hear so
well so he talks louder I'm going to show you here
the actions of alcohol which cause these effects
if I put oil into water what happens
they won't mix that means water will
not dissolve oil now if I put some common
organic oil into this alcohol what happens
the oil separates if dissolves in the alcohol yes
that's the way alcohol affects fatty substances
now just remember that for a minute alcohol has
another action I've seen what it does to bread
I want you to take the bread out Jane you feel it
just pick it up why the breads hard Jack feel it
can you beat it what happened to it the moisture
has been taken out of it alcohol dehydrates it's
a preservative draws the water out of a substance
now maybe you can understand this picture I have
here this is a simple drawing of a nerve cell
in large all parts of the body are made up of
cells which are fed by the bloodstream each cell
is a Manute mass of a semi fluid substance known
as protoblood which is 80 percent water around
the cell is an enclosing membrane and which is
a fatty like substance called lipoid when the
alcohol is in the bloodstream which fades all
the cells it disturbs the fatty like lipoid
making it permeable this permits the alcohol
to enter the cell where it dehydrates some of
the water now this naturally slows the action
of a cell and the person hears cease feels and
thinks less now you remember how the hearing
is dog at the same time the optic nerves are
affected in four ways one effect is to narrow
the span of vision for example if Harry stood
on the street corner with normal vision this
is what he'd seen but after a few glasses of
beer his eye span would be narrowed and this
is all he'd seen you can understand how quickly
a car could hit him before he'd see it that's
what happened another effect is to dim the
perception of colors with normal vision we
see different colors after drinking all
color seems to fade out into peer grade
when the optic nerve is numbed by alcohol objects
seen appear blurred instead of a normal view like
this to the drinker it appears blurred like this
alcohol effects Paul the nerves in the same way
and those that control the movement of our hands
and feet are slowed a driver in a normal condition
can apply the brakes to stop the car in 1/5 of a
second but after a few drinks the same driver may
require 300% more time to act which could be
just the difference between life and death in
every form of athletics the key note of success
is quick thinking speed accuracy and perfect
coordination that's why the number-one rule for
all athletes is no alcohol this is the warning
of Connie Mack the grand old man of baseball I
will not bother with youngsters who drink for
the game requires quick thinking and clean living
old man booze has put more men out of the game
then all the umpires put together dr. Elliott I
never dreamed alcohol could affect the body in
so many different ways especially the brain yeah
but wondering certainly can't do much harm can it
I'm going to let you answer that question
Jack here's a diagram of the nervous system
showing some of the principal nerves as you
know all the nerves in the body connect with
the spinal column which leads up into the
brain now let's look at the brain itself
thank you here's a reproduction of
a section through the head showing
the brain in the top of the spinal cord
at the head of the spinal column is the
medulla oblongata in the top of the head
is the large brain called the cerebrum
down here is a small brain called the cerebellum
now our certain functions of the body are
controlled by each part of the brain in
the medulla are the centers which control the
circulation the digestion and the respiration
these are the light functions without these there
would be no life these vital functions are present
at birth the control of the lungs is sometimes
demonstrated very convincingly the cerebellum
and the back part of the cerebrum composed
the motor sensory area here are motion the
senses sex instinct emotions and other functions
common to animals and men these make possible
the functions of learning with memory they are
developed by use animals have these functions
also though their senses they learn and remember
now humans have a certain part of the brain that
no animal has under this rounded part of the
forest the higher functions located here make
man different from and superior to animals
under the rounded part are the frontal lobes
there is also a thin covering over
the cerebrum this is called the cortex
animals do not have these their foreheads begin at
the end of the nose here in these frontal lobes in
the cortex are located our highest functions
imitation conscience judgment self-control
the power of imitation of imaging hard to do
the power of self-control judgment these the
highest functions of the human mind are the last
to develop now let's consider what happens when
alcohol is in the bloodstream it affects the
brain centers in exactly the reverse order of
their development as we have just seen the first
to be affected are those centers in the frontal
lobes and cortex imitation conscious judgment
self control the next to be affected are the
centers in the back part of the cerebral and in
the cerebellum the senses are dulled the emotions
are freed from control motion is slowed finally
when drinking is continued the functions of life
in the medulla circulation and respiration are
affected and the drinker is near death alcohol
effects first the frontal lobes and the cortex
now Jack do you understand what one drink can
do I think so it means the first drink lessons
self-control weakens the willpower learns the
judgment compare these faculties and anything can
happen anything could happen now always remember
this the first drink releases the controls that
tell us be careful second drink for this reason
is more difficult to refuse the third drink
is eagerly desired just the way it happened
dr. Elliott Jean Harry didn't wanna drink last
night we made it what do you mean Jake she's
right dad Harry never drinks but I insisted I'm
having waffles I told him everybody drinks today
said he wasn't everybody it tried to laugh off we
wouldn't leave him alone so I told him to go home
and ask his mother if he could have an ice-cream
cone then finally gave me out after that it's
just like you said dr. Elliott we we didn't have
to urge him to take a second ring we don't know
what happened to Harry doctor but if he doesn't
come through this we're the ones to play we all
learn by experience Jane what to do what not it
was wrong to urge Harry to drink but you didn't
know the danger of the first drink you didn't know
what alcohol does to the brain if you had known
I'm sure Harry wouldn't be at a hospital now how
can we ever face his love yes this is dr. Elliott
hey guys right
prepare for surgery immediately
now he has taken a turn for the worst how long
will the operation team I don't know don't give
up hope we'll do everything we can for it for
Jean what'll we do I don't know but no matter
what happened that I kind of feel like we've
got no start I've learned something from all
this haven't you yes just remember yes remember
the responsibility and asking anyone to take
a drink remember the result of the first
three remember alcohol effects first man's
highest faculties remember dr. Charles Mayo the
famous surgeon said it's the brain that counts